hey guys welcome back to the swish
warlad podcast and some of you may have
already heard the massive news this week
but the great bowdoin barrett is now on
swish how good is that the episode with
bodhi is still the most popular waterlet
episode of all time and it's fair to say
that he is one of the coolest lads on
the planet
bodhi has always been great at
connecting with his fans and he is
always doing good things for the charity
which is close to his heart which is
upside downs if you're keen on a swish
from bodhi or any of the other lads on
there head to hayswish.com and just for
being a world lead listener if you enter
the code water led you will get an extra
10 off it's super easy to use and up to
70 of the proceeds do go to kiwi kids
charities is super cool stuff
also pomeroys who make the best coffee
bean in new zealand and a wide range of
delicious teas are giving water led
listeners a 20 off discount all of their
teas and coffee including your very own
waterline coffee with the temperature
cooling off now there's not much better
than a nice warm tea to start the day or
even finish the day my go-to right now
is the peach and apricot
it is seriously good stuff i'll leave a
link in the description for you to click
on
and the code for that is land03
and before we get into this one i do
have the greatest lad around tim bateman
to tell you about exciting new
opportunity he has to offer you cheers
jimmy
are you looking for an exciting career
for life after rugby my name's tim
bateman and i've been a professional
rugby player for the last 17 years
my plan for life after rugby was to get
into the well-being and recovery
industry so i built ostudio new
zealand's largest well-being and
recovery centre despite the challenges
of covert we've seen consistent growth
in our business and we've decided to
expand ostudio throughout new zealand
and abroad
it's an exciting time for the well-being
industry and we're looking for top lads
to be a part of it by opening your own o
studio
if you're interested head to ostudio dot
co dot nz slash lad to inquire back to
the show
[Music]
[Music]
what a lad i have for you all today one
of the stars of super rugby in my
opinion one of the most underrated
players in the game he's been
consistently one of the best performers
every time he plays whether it's been
for the blues tasman or north harbour
and of course he is an absolute lad who
no doubt will have plenty of stories to
share it is one of the greats mark to
lear welcome brother
what's up brother cheers for having me
man mate finally we got i got you on
i've been waiting to get you on for a
long long time but yeah i finally did it
actually i've been we've been talking
about this ever since i was at tessie
finally got to get it done man right and
we must address that to start off i
guess elephant in the room my heart's
just still recovering from
the news that you announced a few weeks
ago you're back to north harbor you're
leaving tazzy talk me through this
decision
wow
for me it was a tough decision well like
um
how was where it started for me and
i kind of wanted us just to get back
home kind of my family's like real close
there so
mad love for tassie and what they did
for me and opportunity they gave to me
and i like a lot of the boys i met down
there like good friends and stuff i
still
you know communicate nowadays you know
yourself included by the forget you
right so now i've made a lot of good
dudes down in tassie and i won't forget
my memories there but for me it was just
coming back home to where i started from
uc
was it always going to be staying in new
zealand because were you looking
overseas as well
yeah but i was kind of like
trying to chase that money for but i was
just like
but then like i got a lot of convincing
you know to stay and
yeah i kind of was just like i had to
make the decision to stay so yeah just
at that point was that convincing from
up top have you heard much from the all
blacks obviously your form has been on
absolute fire this year is that where
it's come from
no no no i was just kind of like um my
coaches and stuff you know i had real
good like conversations with them and
they kind of just you know convinced me
to stay and i was kind of i was kind of
good bro still young so it's all good
yeah i can't believe you're only 25 hey
and how many more years are you still at
the blues in your contract
uh
right now this is my last season um kind
of trying to get back into talks with
them about like signing another one or
two so yeah
yeah so the plan is to stay in new
zealand for a couple more years see how
you go
yeah i think right now kind of just
because we've got something good at the
blues that they you know they're real
the coaches just want to keep building
on that you know so
like keeping the right players around i
guess they just want to keep trying to
you know because you know when like you
got something good and stuff you know
they're like gotta keep the players
around you know that's keeping you going
so they're kind of like on their person
right and they'll definitely be wanting
to keep yeah your form again has been on
fire um what do you put that down to
you're consistently playing awesome
footy um i i'm
got like good like players around you as
well man like uh
like mentally you have to get up for and
physically as well but just like having
the right players around you you know
we're all like in this like this world
together and we just
really want to just do something you
know like well here and this legacy and
just like leave it for the boys you know
do something good for like
this team and like the people that's
going to come later on
we just want to leave it behind knowing
that you know we left it in good hands
and stuff like that so i can the players
as well though that i like i said we
have around us they're just they're just
keen and
you know like it just you just feed off
the energy because everyone's hungry for
it
every week you're just up for the
challenge bro right and you are on the
end of a pretty um nice back line too
hey there's some pretty good players
inside you have you found playing
outside all of them ah grateful man
grateful
like it's a dangerous backline bar like
you got a lot of like game breakers and
a lot of dudes that like [ __ ] want to
get the ball in their hands and stuff
and
that's mean bro just to you know play
play amongst them and you know get to
experience that team effort on the field
and just going into those dark dark
places together even the hurt lockers
and yeah just kind of experiencing it
all together so yeah a lot gets spoken
about roger's uh footwork but yeah right
your footwork have you got them in the
one-on-one
he's nice of her but um
a lot of the boys in the background man
they're
get them in a one-on-one situation it's
pretty dangerous to stop where so yeah
and how influential has bodhi been since
moving up to the blues
he's been he's been good but he's just
there's rugby smarts man he's just
real composed and real professional
about his work and
i can like having him mostly with us
because we're still kind of like a real
i want to say young background but
there's a lot of young players but then
just having him like you know leading
leading the charge and just you know
commanding us as real good workers
a lot of us are real
young and emotional players we kind of
like lose it a bit and just having him
like real composed just leading us is
real good man you see it out there when
we play bro
it's exciting times for blues fans a big
year ahead i think you know if you guys
want to jump on the leg and jump on it
[Laughter]
or maybe as a second team but they'll
never never overtake the canes for me
but it is cool to see them doing so well
yeah man that's good bro but i do want
to talk about you i do want to talk
about your upbringing i know you've got
some of the best genetics in rugby your
mum's um sam and your dad's from south
africa am i right
yeah yeah yeah my mom's um for someone
crazy story man she's um
one of the like strongest woman i've
ever
had in my life and alvaro all the
blessings i would have not received man
was crazy so everything she did for me
catered to me i'm grateful for that
old man was um
he wasn't really much into my life like
uh growing up so i mostly grew up on my
like someone's side
and um being like a young
or dark skinned island there's like
that's not you don't find that much in
growing up uh like west lakeland ways
it's just crazy you meet a lot of police
and
they just see you and you start speaking
their language and they're just like hey
but now i grew up um you know
it was challenging at times but now
grateful for man
i wouldn't change your birth no growing
up so how did your parents mate bro i
wouldn't even nervous
i was i knew i was in like wellington
somewhere like that's where they
uh south africa to new zealand
yeah something like that but and then
i just remember like it was like a
falling nakano and
my um someone said came down to
wellington and picked me up and then
took me back to auckland i think my mom
stayed south african dad captained back
to south africa and stuff like that and
yeah that was all she wrote
just been back to play in south africa
and just come back
did he play footy nah i don't know
if he did i would want to play him smack
him
i don't know i don't know i don't know
much about him to be honest
so then you grew up in west auckland um
so you're can you speak um samoan fluent
yeah it was like my first language yeah
yeah before english
yeah and then gibberish gibberish is
lovely
i grew up um and my house was just like
um i had real strict um parents at the
time my parents my grandparents that
raised me at the time
so i wish i called my parents they
raised me and my house was just like
they only spoke someone so it was easy
for me to learn and that's the first
language i learned
and then english was just like our
second language because we were going to
school and just learning it there so
yeah was that hard for you at school
not being able to speak english that
well um
yeah it was at the time but like
majority of kids like they just keep
going to school you just pick up like
you just pick up use of things and like
heaps of the things like i would say and
stuff you wouldn't get it from like like
your mom and dad heaps of things are
like like just heaps of slangs and stuff
and i remember like when i used to speak
to parents and i used to like say
something
like check or say something like that
heaps of the words we would learn as
like not words you would learn from like
a mom or dad
yeah
and what were you like what were you
like as a teenager uh
i'll say um
i kept to myself to be honest uh
i had like a small circle and then
to be honest was kind of i was kind of
lost in like um
i was a bit out there to be honest um
just
had like the wrong role models and stuff
around me
in other areas just like um
i missed that west or yourself and stuff
you have like
not the best role models so you grew up
thinking like oh like this that's life
for me and
that's that's what's going to be like
and so you get exposed to some other
things and
i reckon i'm real grateful you know
fortunate to like experience rugby like
real late and
like school days
but like
growing up as a teenager out here was
and you don't really have that big
influence of like trying to chase dreams
and trying to move your life you kind of
just your role models are like
you know what i'm saying like you know
there's people that kind of don't see
like the world
a massive like um opportunity you know
these guys just
do what they do to get past you know so
were you involved in gangs is that the
sort of crowd that you were hanging
around um
it was a there was a lot of like around
our areas and stuff so you just kind of
you kind of don't want to scoop to that
stand and stuff like you just you kind
of want to do good mostly for like kids
growing up like in our ways to show them
other opportunities but yeah that's
that's uh like out these ways it's
massive so so then how did you had it
where did rugby fit in amongst all this
um i was kind of lucky one of my close
friends um back in school days was like
like hitting me up like all right bring
your boots come trout first 15 and i was
like
i hate her first thing cause all the
boys put throughout the [ __ ] like they
put that
stuff like that so like i never thought
of like playing and i had a brother that
was playing and then
kind of asked him for his boots and then
he gave it to me and i tried brian
i haven't i just started loving rugby
ever since man so yeah i was like
it was late year 12 or something like
that started playing so yeah so you
hadn't really played through the junior
ranks nah um
i was one of those because i was just if
i was gonna play i'll just play with my
mates just to muck around and
get into like those little scuffles and
just start talking about that like
like that you know like
little kid things when so nah yeah i
didn't really play much like eighth
grade rugby just kind of had it at the
end of high school so yeah but you must
have been naturally pretty gifted to
just be able to rock up to a first 15
child and carve it up
ah
oh yeah i reckon it comes back down to
i was lucky like i was like
just naturally like fit and just good at
running
too much jumping fences and running away
from
i was just lucky where i got some good
genes and yeah man just never looked
back so yeah just jam off this is what i
got and and you've got a pretty um
powerful mindset too don't you so you've
always been pretty confident in your own
ability
yeah harder man um
i reckon any like young teenager
growing up man just be confident in
yourself and your ability to you know
you can do whatever you want bro only
your mindset can like stop you from
doing what you want so
yeah i was real confident growing up so
how did you get that mindset because i
love it i want it um
hey man you can have it whenever you are
i guess just growing up and like um your
environment and like the people around
you and um i've seen a lot of losses
growing up and
um seeing a lot of people you know
like go the wrong way and
i guess
at that time or like in that place you
kind of just don't want to like put
yourself in that situation and kind of
think like how you would get better or
be better than they were in terms
like i've had a lot of losses to get to
where i am today like it wasn't all
uphill for me like i never just walked
in and i was like the most talented
everything i had to do i had to work
hard for
and i rather like that because then at
the end of the day you truly know who
you are like who you are and what you
work for so i'm grateful in that way
because
like growing up
i was always like that for any of like
my brothers cousins or friends or
anything they always had to work hard
for what they wanted and
for me that was just kind of like that
was just kind of the mindset like every
day you ought to work for what you want
there's a saying that those has as
crackers it's like when your name gets
caught
like someone needs you are you going to
stand up for it or you're just going to
be a [ __ ] or walk away like it's like
me
like that's a mean thing because it's
like actually true man yeah some people
get like the opportunity
and then the other like
rise to it or they shy away from it so
that's kind of like mindset yeah love it
and you always stand up i love that so
what was your pathway from school how
did you get into the professional footy
side of things um so after school i got
like this academy contract
for harbour
and um i just yeah just took off from
there i mean i was just academy training
and that
that was a real
any any other rugby players that talk
about like they know what academy was
like man they run you to the ground they
they train you they just get you into
that routine of like professional footy
and i remember like the routine of it
was like
waking up
at four get ready to have all and i had
no license and i was driving all day to
the shore
and i think i'll take my old man's car
obviously but i just use it i'll just
take off i'll take off the train train
all the way till seven have a shower
then i'll go straight to work and i'll
work all day till
four or five and then i'll get some food
and then weird afternoon trainings for
club
and then it's like that for the whole
week until you'll probably only have
friday or saturday and then you're
playing and then it's just repeat yeah
and it was just like that for like a
good it was like a cycle man you just
keep doing it for like months and it
just like breaks you and you're just
like that's either you crack it or you
don't burn and you see so many players
that like are mean
and they don't they don't break through
their cycle like they just like easy or
they just like think it's going to be
handed to them and like i guess i was
lucky because there was a few of us that
like made it through that academy day
and
it just really made you
chase what you really wanted if you get
what i mean so yeah
and then then i got my first cracker
maratin when i was a
i think it was 2016 for my first debut
for for harbor i was real young
and i was just like keen to play and
stuff i had mean players i liked such
and that was like the thing where
growing up out these days like other
players in your position or like that
were like in the same pathway as you
yeah but it was crazy because they would
like i remember i had tavita lee where
he needs to help me out so much like he
was a mean mentor for me and he'd always
like
tell me not to do this and like don't
hang out with these people man and just
like it was crazy right he was of power
at the time so i had him as like my
mentor kind of and he just helped me out
and those other players like that play
club rugby that um
you know what i mean that i looked up to
they helped me out so much as well so
i'm grateful because like a lot of boys
in like my areas like if they knew like
you're that new kid on the block or you
were there new cadets coming up and
they knew like you're on their pathway
they would help you out so much and like
just look after you and like nurture you
so like i had real good players going on
a club rugby and even at um not harbor
so it was real good man so cool to hear
so when you first got your crack when
you had your debut were you still a
super confident kid did you did you know
you were ready
um
yeah i was like i knew i was ready but
then like you know how professional foot
is like real different like um
it's not like just club rugby we can
just
get the ball from the 22 and just run
this air on it
wow you know i don't mean like it's not
yeah it's not like club review you can
just do whatever you want and
i remember i wasn't like the best like
my debut i remember i made like a few
mistakes and stuff but like i saw me
just had like good players that just
looked after me and
just kind of taught me a lot of things
um
and even like the coaches at the time
had like checker
uh who was
tc was there some coventry yeah um
and then like those guys were just
harder like helping me out or like being
young
getting exposed to it just like they
just chucked me into the deep end oh
you're starting on the right wing i was
like oh you're hard
well that was me bro that was me now
i'll never like want it any other way
and then is it true after that season
you were approached by
uh gordon titchens to play for samoa
sevens yeah i was i was um
yeah i remember he approached me and i
was like at the time like
seven wasn't i was just playing sevens
with like my club team and just i was
just for fun like i just like to
check the boots on and just have like
jam with the boys it was kind of like
that
and then he was like
trying to get me to jam like
professionally but i like really doesn't
see seven just like a mean i like rather
fifteen swirls like more
like in seven you get so much open space
you can do whatever you want
fifteen just like real
clinical you only get like a little bit
of time to breathe when you get the ball
like shut down like in seconds so i felt
like 15 was like a more better sport i'm
not disregarding like seven sevens is
fun but it wasn't me you know
um cool so then the next pathway was a
call up to the canes uh yeah a six week
training call up to the keynes
how did that one come about so i just
finished pre-season of um blues and i
was like um injury
i was injury cover
um for vince i think i was for vince or
someone that had like a long
season injury or something like that
and i'm going down to the kings i met a
lot of good dudes that like i still talk
to nowadays and it was crazy bro you saw
that team that's when i first met you as
well man and you saw that king's team
man that king's team was back but
there's all the young dudes at hunters
and stuff so
now i got my first opportunity to go
down and
yeah i enjoyed it it was real cool bro
mate i do remember it like it was
yesterday i remember you were running on
the wang i was at fullback and i think
it was a gamer you know shoulder on
hey i got one-on-one you were just
cruising up to me and then you went
quack quack quack and absolutely skinned
me but you're such a lad that you just
went down and pretending like i'd got
you you didn't run and score the try and
i was like holy this guy is good who is
this guy where's he coming from sign him
up he is the man
it was good times london well he's mad a
lot of good dudes for us so now i was i
mean i was mean to experience that as
well
what was the biggest difference
obviously you had done the preseason
with the blues how did those two
cultures um compare
um
well at the time like this one the booze
or like the blues was just like building
like the the foundations and stuff they
have now um
or pre-season was hard
or any precision in his heart you know
but at that time pre-season was real
hard and
i guess
just coming to kings and
kings are
around i don't know how to say the way
two different whole team like there were
way different like cultures and
everything
i remember when i came down to keynes
like keynes had like such a
like even on defense they had such a
kill mindset where like losing a bit
passive and then kill here and all of
that
but like when i remember coming to kings
i was just like
kill kill kill everything man down kept
going i was just like like damn this is
way different like that
so like it was me getting to play
alongside um a lot of you like young
talent coming through the kings like
that they have now
was mean as well to experience all of
that so which i was like grateful for
brian yeah i'll just say like meeting a
lot of new players down there was me
and just expecting two different
cultures rugby coaches and just trying
to like you know enjoy a while like you
were there so yeah it was mean for me
man i remember you watch uh watching you
play for the hunters which is the
hurricane's development against japan at
pothodor park remember sitting up on the
bank with andrew goodman next to me
asking me who's a player he should look
out for and i remember saying watch mark
talia watch him watch and he's the man
and you absolutely carved up that japan
international team that day and i'm not
sure what happened since there but a
couple of years later you were down at
tasman so talk me through that whole
process
um
yeah
so you're the guy that today you're
together
uh grateful man um
i just remember i was like um on my last
year of harvard and um i was just like
oh i'm keen to experience something else
and
just keen like to
you know try something like i like i
don't want i didn't want to get like
comfortable i wanted to learn more
player
like um i was coming off i was coming
off there like hunters with like
hurricanes and stuff and
remember played that might attend season
of harbor what she was like we lost like
shimmies and stuff and
it was real cool and stuff but like
as a i was still a young outside and
then we like had no like i would say
like leadership as outsides but that's
how i felt and i just for me i wanted to
learn more as a like an outsider and
develop my own game
i felt like i was in the
like even today i still don't feel like
i'm the complete package like you know
i'm still trying to get it get my game
better and
try and find little ways to like you
know get like the mindset right and
just keep building because i reckon if
you just keep having that growth mindset
you just keep like getting better and
better
so i felt like that was a massive
influence at the time like i wanted it
just to get better
and then um
i remember
towards the end of their um my team
season i was like oh you know like um i
mean some good dudes down and the
hunters like you know you right i
remember radios how do i like brian
and then yeah where i just locked in and
then
yeah i just remember just signing in
i was like that is what it is now i'm on
my way down to nelson so
and then yeah where i just took off from
there and just never looked back just
enjoyed the footy ever since i was down
there
mate yeah what was the biggest
difference to going from north harbor to
tasman how did those two environments
compare
i ain't like like i said like coaches
are like
two team coaches were way different
like you you know the teddy boys like
you know what they're like man
they're crazy man and just
just to come from like harvard like
come from harbour to tessie
and like tell you like a real small
community and like the boys like they
get around each other like one day they
just throw out a message and like you
know hey dude show up to like ricky and
just oh yo you know i mean like there's
a real small community and the boys
majority just have themselves down there
so
like it was mean for me and to
experience that and
you just get like freedom basically but
i just do whatever you want and it just
leads to the field where
mean of your culture that's that's what
i say about tassie man
if you ever go down to
enjoy it
so then
after your cain's little stint you did
get picked up by the blues was that was
ever a decision there did the keynes
want to try and keep you how hard was
that one um yeah at the time i like but
i had like um family like problems going
on as well
so like
for me it was always to come back home
that was like the first thing i felt
like oh no man i need a and then come
back to my family and stuff because
uh for me
my family is like the priority i don't
want anything to happen to my fans well
i'm not there so something happened to
my fans and i wasn't there and i i felt
like hurt
so
when the blues offered it was just easy
for me it was just easy for me to come
home
no disregard to the kings the good dudes
and stuff especially when i was down
there
but yeah it was just easy for me to come
back home so yeah i just
signed and just came home mate and you
speak about that moment because i
remember that vividly as well when
you're at the keynes and you we hit the
shock news that your brother had been
um punched and killed so mate how hard
was that for you to handle and deal with
ah manners
that's like something i wouldn't want
like no one to experience man like uh
yeah man i was a real sad time mostly
for my family and stuff so
you know
like um
remember in japan and all that stuff
happening i was just like trying to get
back home
um yeah i came back home and
my
brother was just laying there on the bed
and
on the hospital bed and then um was just
for me it was just like um
like you never think that would ever
happen like i mean about like enjoying
and experiencing you know like having
those moments with your brothers and
stuff
i'll never get that back now but i'm
grateful it made me cherish what i have
more in front of me and
that's what i mean about like you know
like family and stuff so um
in a way it's a mess of learning and
just being safe out there
yeah like it always turns up so fast so
um
yeah it was just a mess of i like for me
and my family is a massive running curve
so
you know you have to take it on the chin
as it is and
yeah i was just saying if you're out
there drinking and you're out on the
boats look after yourself man that's
crazy yeah such a crazy story do you
know much about the whole incident
um
not to be honest i don't really know
much about it and i and i hate pondering
on it because it just makes me think
yeah
yeah and it just makes me wanna like it
makes you like
oh what would you say like because you
can't turn back time the more you ponder
about it more you're thinking about
something that's just a waste
like that is what it is he's gone you
know we can only cherish the moments and
stuff we have before like my family
always do it so
i'm grateful for like all the blessings
that he brought to my family all the
smiles and laughters they did
my brother's gone you never get him back
any of the memories love so right so sad
and how's that moment sort of changed
your life
i had a massive impact on like me in
general um
kind of
[Music]
like for me like losing something that
like important um
i kind of like you just find out like
what your values like what your like
real values are like what you put in
front of you for me it just kind of like
came down to like i like i had to be
like family first and
i had to do all of this
like kind of thinking and how i was
going to live my life from now on and
cater to my knees because like i just
had a massive impact on my family like
my mom go real after that just like too
much stress and stuff like that so
and then
like at the time i was like slowly
seeing my like own family like because i
got a mess of family and like
losing like a piece like that to my
family was like massive and then it
started hurting us real bad and then at
that time like my old man was just like
bringing us together and like trying to
find ways to like build us like back
and stuff like that
so like in a way you just kind of
just find out like what your real values
are and what you hold like truth to
yourself and
um those are like kind of like what i
used to like drive me now every day you
know finding your gratitude and finding
what you're grateful for what you have
in front of you who you love and all of
that stuff so that's what keeps me going
today and i can if anyone can find any
other stuff you don't have to go to a
dark place like that now to find that
stuff but like some people find it
harder than
others you know it's not gonna come easy
but if you can find those like values
and just keep that in front of you and
just let that like
stare like you're kind of like life in
like a way you know it's like real
strong so you just keep like believing
that and just keep getting that way man
powerful was it hard for it not to
affect your form you're obviously you're
still playing
around this time
um
others are like i'll say it in a way
like people could
they could either use it to their
advantage or they could
yeah like destroy it from it
in a way
i think i was lucky because like the
mindset i had and
um i'm just a real strong believer of
like um
like because i had our pray and all of
this you know
i had real good people around me and i
just like used it to kind of my
advantage you know i mean like um
i just had i was like i knew like my
brother would be watching over me
and
because my brother was like hard on to
sports and stuff so like for me to go
out there and play like i'll probably
wear them on my sleeve and stuff now and
then and it just makes me like grateful
because you know this could be my
brother playing well you know could have
been like in those situations so either
you use it to your ability or
like don't be a guy that's going to let
it destroy you though man yeah life was
with sure man
just
find something that you want to do
believe on it your dreams chaser
anything man the only people stopping
you is yourself and don't let other like
other people talk smack and stop you
from doing what you want to do but i
just keep chasing dreams oh i love it so
powerful so then you got your crack with
the blue so you forgot your debut how
did you find that one
ah bro it's crazy sort of debut um
i remember we came off like i'm like a
mean as um preseason
with blues as well and i was just crazy
like i remember i like
i almost lost my front like my whole
front set of teeth because of um
training me and money headquarters and i
was bringing them up
i was like oh my mouth was just like
pouring blood and i was like nah
like well i rushed up to the dentist and
they like put like a brace on my teeth
keep it like together
when i was just like in the like things
just being like oh bro i'm out this week
i can't even play
i then um everyone went back to training
the next day and then leon was like
sitting there he's like how do you feel
and i was like oh [ __ ] i don't feel good
like
uh like my teeth are still like [ __ ]
that was like oh then like cracking up
and then i was like um he just hit me
like straight up he was like is that the
you're gonna get this opportunity i'm
gonna give you and take it or
you're gonna shy away from it
and i was just sitting there like hey
what's the honorable he's like
i want to start you on the right wing
and i was just like nah
and i like couldn't promote i didn't
know anything because my teeth was so
sensitive and i was like nah bro i want
to lose my teeth this game
was like oh my god
but then yeah give me the opportunity
brandon ah that was mean i was mean to
go out there we lost that game i think
aaron couldn't kick like a drop call oh
like a drop kick right
right and then yeah broadcast was like
uh
then the next week we were playing like
the seders we lost that at home as well
where's life
so yeah it was like two close games but
that is what it is then off to
australia
and then off to south africa after that
so how did you find um traveling with
the blues and traveling with the squad
obviously going to australia south
africa how did you find that i was on it
was like an unreal experience um
i think i was like fortunate because it
was like the last south africa trip so i
was grateful to get like the end of a
man is unreal just to like
i guess that's like kind of like the
dream bro like you know what i mean like
just the traveling and getting to play
in different places and
just enjoying like um the vibes that you
get over there and
the environments and stuff and just
being with the players that you trained
with
yeah i'd say like that's like the dream
just traveling and playing bar so for me
being that
young kid just thinking like you know
coming out of west auckland and just
being like yo just play with my mates to
getting to travel all the world and play
rugby man i guess i'm real grateful for
man and that's
that's like the thing like you you just
enjoy the moments that you get i messed
up the team and
like who you're woof at that time as
well but i never thought i'd be with the
boys training at alexandra park and in
next one
johannesburg and flipping cape town bros
it was unreal
and what was it like going back to oh
not going back but going to south africa
how did it feel
it was mean for me but it's like kind of
getting to
meet my other half kind of you know what
i mean like
it's crazy but
just
getting to experience it firsthand and
just being there and just enjoying your
bar and then playing footy over there
was unreal against them as well so nah
man i just like took it all in and it
was just like this is crazy i'm actually
doing this you know yeah yeah and i was
like all i just said before but it's
like a dream so you're just living it so
you just enjoy it
it's a crazy place say south africa like
when you see the difference between the
poverty and all that side it's just a
whole different ball game eh
wait they're from man
in new zealand this should be great for
me
[Music]
and like media and stuff
and then to go over there and actually
be in like that part of the country on
the world i mean it's just like it's
crazy
but your form didn't stop you didn't
stop carving it up on the field was it
at the back end of that year you were
named in the north south game yeah um
and not for herself i didn't get to play
got hurt with the hard work that we
wanted to take a
a kicking option so they pretend
it was our your street
that was mean experience part went down
and you know enjoyed it as i said it was
mean bro did you feel like you were
close to the all blacks now that you're
involved with that side
um
at the time yeah at the time yeah i was
like oh yo got your foot in the door you
know
coaches are looking at you you just kind
of just
for me i kind of just don't want to get
a little get to me like i just don't
want to play footy
just
play for the reasons like my team was
playing like you know winning the title
and all of that stuff
when i was down there i was like you
know you got your foot in the door so
just keep playing footy and you just
kind of don't look back you just keep
trying to play bro and you mentioned a
couple of titles so you definitely had a
big influence on a couple of titles over
that following season first someone was
with tasman and we played auckland in
auckland um what do you remember about
that game i was crazy real physical game
man both teams are up for or
i just remember like um
we just had like that two or three
months which is real ruthless you know
we had to compete for everything
auckland wasn't going to give it to us
easy man and look like a mean team as
well so
to get one up on them at their home
ground was never easy as uh i remember
we went there earlier this season i
throughout the season they pumped us
they actually armed us and we're like
nah man
go back there and like kind of get
revenge and you know beat them for that
last game but i was unreal and um i know
like still to this day like
when i talk to like some of the oakland
boys and if we ever bring it up there i
was like nah shut up like
that was cracked up man but uh meanwhile
was mean it was crazy and then the
follow the same year the next
competition you're involved in was super
ugly trans tasman which you happen to
win that as well this time you're
playing for the blues at auckland what
was that final like oh man it was a
i said unreal experience mostly for like
the blues like you hear all of us like
we haven't won a title in like this long
and all that but i felt like it's
finally like putting like uh a stump on
the comp you know what i mean like
letting everyone know that we're here to
play it's not the same blues team from
like the previous years like this is a
whole different like team now
we're more hungry we compete we just we
just want to show especially like for
our fans man like back at home
from like the online we just want to
show you guys how much
for us that we just wanted to show them
how much it meant to us to play for our
jersey
i think like over the like years we were
losing like our own values and
our standards for our own selves so
for us it was just a mess of like to
show you as well hit a play we're here
to compete and we're here to win the
title fools so it was just a stuff like
winning for our city so i was kind of
like that and
whoever else was supporting the blues at
the time so yeah right so cool when once
you've won it i know you're pretty good
at um the two being the tour leader
holding that yellow jersey for a long
time you've got a hell of a quick skull
on you
how did you go oh i told you that bro i
don't know
right i saw you thought the tasman went
on for about three weeks
no one could get it off yeah you're
incredible
i was running away from them bro i
wasn't telling you
the person that's got a mean skeleton
was reeks for he entering for us so
kenny oh that's right
yeah has he got yet
yeah i think so
i think he does
and then he like rubs it in your face so
trying to talk about it
i could imagine
oh but then last year i wasn't as
successful you picked up an injury sort
of halfway through the season on your
shoulder real niggly timing for you how
was it to deal with that
and i didn't even i think i broke it as
well like i was like shocked
i just went to school try bro playing
you know
playing up against the tiny fuzzy i
remember suck was playing
[ __ ] i just still can't believe it to
this day like i actually got injured
because
i usually just play injury-free never
get injured and then just one time just
go to school like a normal driver and
put the ball down and
broke my scapula into burn i remember
just walking back to the halfway and i
was just like
like just going like this and i could
just hear like bones clunking and i was
like
surely this was like
like something i thought i was just like
oh nice must be like out of place or
something photos like my shoulders out
of a socket or something
i went back home the next day
just got a scan saw my scapula and super
and i was like nah
like surely that's not my family
all right y'all broke me right i didn't
get to play for that last jersey season
and
had surgery like the next two days after
i was
straight away i
don't like that type of dude like
i wouldn't let her like hold me down
like i'll just be like [ __ ] or
something's gonna get trained and i get
better
and like watching my teams go out there
and play and i couldn't even like help
out i could only help out like in like
the classroom
[Music]
meetings and stuff like that so
that was the only way i could contribute
i couldn't contribute and then like
towards the end of the season i started
getting into like a lot of running so
yeah that was like um that was me for
this you know i still tell this day i'm
like nah never again
never again
happens
so was that your first injury
yeah that was my first ever like injury
that's crazy yeah
and that was like a massive one so i was
like
i thought it'll never happen to me
crazy man
yeah and you've spoken about um you just
wanted to get back in there and i know
you're a nightmare for the tasman
physios and doctors
trying to keep you out of contact and
stuff
i remember like um i was like not even
healed yet and i was like trying to like
get into contact and stuff and
be like nah you still got like six weeks
away nice to be like i still like cussed
them out like i was like
[ __ ] they tell me to do like they'll be
like what the [ __ ] this guy
there's a majority of the time i was
just like like i don't know how to say
it bro but like
i just wanted to get out there again
like
at the time like i was just feeling like
that's all i had and i mostly rather she
like seen the boys play
and i had like lister
and like even because it was me and
tully like me and tully were out for the
season
and
me and him were just talking and just
watching the boys play and we'd like
if we didn't get the result we wanted or
would just win the game
it was just like
kind of home for us because we were like
our team was getting like you know it's
not the same
[Music]
man that's how massive the tasty culture
was for us and we just wanted to
like
add a little value to their like success
or for them to win
so like
i remember we were trying to get back in
early and just try and run around and
stuff and as you guys always get us out
and
for us it was just like we would kind of
lose that thing just all like all right
let us
help
but they're only trying to do their jobs
and stuff
so yeah sorry to them if they're
watching
[Laughter]
so when you went up to auckland and you
did your pre-season did you feel
confident on your shoulder it caused no
issues
yeah
my shoulder is good now but like i was
lucky we had good physios done it says
he good physios up at blues so they just
like maintained me real well looked
after me
i've done a lot of like shoulder rehab
and stuff
and then
next thing you know i was in a preseason
game and
tackling and i felt like i was all good
and then
from there just yeah
ever since it's just been jamming till
now so yeah it's grateful man
right and jamming is what you've been
doing you've been killing it this season
have you have you had any feedback from
from the oven nah
nah man i don't know
a lot of people think like you get
feedback with stuff i don't know i think
they
they do their own thing brian if they
want to get in contact with you they get
in contact with you but now i've just
been trying to jam bro and just do me
um you know i wouldn't even know very
like because i don't even think about it
like that you know what i mean like i
just
right now it's just
like blues is where it's at for me right
now and that's what i'm thinking of
and
a lot of boys just want to win another
title or you know do good for the club
so that's kind of what like the mindset
is right now you just
trying to do that bro i guess the thing
that makes it interesting for you is
you've got the possibility to represent
south africa or samoa is that right yeah
so have you look have you looked into in
either of those pathways or for you now
is it just purely trying to make the all
blacks and see what happens
ah it's not even like the all blacks
it's just like
like for me this year was just trying to
get back into like a confident like
playing style and like just get back out
there and just try and enjoy footy
because when i lost that tasty season i
was like
didn't play 44 ages and i was like just
fast forward and i was like man i
haven't played it so long
i just want to get back into playing and
enjoying footy so when i got the chance
to play again this year i just feel like
i was telling all the boys i just want
to enjoy the movements because i didn't
know if it was going to be my last year
before it's going to be my teasing was
blues and all that so i was just like i
want to just enjoy it bro and then
yeah i was just like that was kind of
like the mindset and
i didn't really think of playing for any
international team you know like
for me like if it's there even if you
really want to play it's all up to you
brian
you know you chase what you want but i
don't really see it like that
so if south africa came calling at the
end of um super rugby to try and get you
into the 2023 world cup for south africa
i could imagine you'd be pretty lethal
on the wing for them would you accept
something like that
honestly it was like
it was like appealing to me and it came
out to me like and i was just like in
the mood for like um
like oh i sound like i don't know
anything like nothing like you know
teams of trash and all of this i'm just
like saying you know if they came at the
time and and i felt like in the moment
it was right yeah huh
would be for like any other team if
someone approached me at the right time
i'll be like you're sweet
but i'll just do it
but right now my mindset and where i'm
at right now it's just kind of like
blues right now if you give up
yeah may i think your phone's going to
be blowing up over the next few weeks
from samoa
and maybe the all blacks mate
i like it
and what like i know you're fully
focused on the blues at the moment but
you haven't signed for the blues next
year
is overseas a goal for you at any point
or you're pretty happy staying in
auckland close to your family um right
now like yeah like uh like before like
earlier on the season i was like how do
i trying to think of like how to get
like more money and stuff like that for
the fans and stuff
i started thinking about like um family
and i like don't want to be far from
them so i was just kind of like right
now i just want to kind of be close to
him
close to
just
right now just trying to sort out some
stuff off blue so hopefully it goes well
and
you're locked in again so he's just
trying to sort that out bro person and i
do like to know what guy's plans are
after rugby i know um you've probably
got some pretty elaborate plans for what
you want to do after rugby
you want to share any
i like i like for me like i wanted to
give back to like the youth
um in a way
i wanted to do like um like i just
wanted to go to schools and stuff i'm
trying to do that now like wanted to go
back to schools and just show them that
there's like way better pathways than
what they think because majority of kids
out my ways don't really think there's
heaps of pathways for them
and
they think that they're limited to like
just normal nine or five jobs and
working factory jobs and
kind of like i remember when i was
growing up i had like um some rugby
players come to my school
and i didn't really think of it as much
but then when i really thought about our
stuff uh you can actually do something
like this because i was like thinking
you had to be like real talented or you
have to have like the best genetics or
you just it all comes back down to just
hard work and what you see
and i feel like if
like any rugby player not like any rugby
player like rugby players just out there
like you know playing on tv and stuff if
they can just go to schools and you know
speak to like some kids you spark like
that thing in their mind you know what i
mean like
and then they'll just be like oh yo i
couldn't it doesn't even have to be
rugby could be whatever they're chasing
or pursuing at the time
and then they'll just really more focus
on like their goals and whatever they
want to chase for so for me i wanted to
do that i wanted to like go to schools
or whatever it is
and a way to speak to like young
like young kids that don't really have
options or they don't really think they
have options uh but i would probably
for me after rugby i'll probably get
back into like um building one of my
brothers have like a building company so
i would probably get into yeah that bro
that one came out of nowhere you had me
with the mentoring thing i didn't i
didn't see the building so did you do a
bit of building
um before rugby
yeah a little bit a little bit bro i was
like
my brother took me for like a few
few weeks and stuff into building maybe
slave away so
i've been there by so it'll be something
i would be keen to get into so yeah i
couldn't imagine you on a building site
actually you can't right
a man very
i want to do like yeah i like a lot of
brothers that's some building now so
yeah
it'll be something i'm like looking
forward to authoring me bro yeah good
what a build out love it
what are stories
some of the great stuff some inspiring
stuff throughout that podcast but as
always we've gone to our instagram for
some questions
and mark talia you have a massive
following so we've got plenty of
questions here for you
first question a little bit about the
two a litre one um how many malibu can
you drink before taking off your top
uh i would say zero bro i didn't i
didn't take off my shirt for melody's
sticker
okay next one uh favorite new zealand
player of all time
i'll probably go
i was into like um
like the wingers i'll say like
jericho
yeah
yeah i'll probably get your rich prizes
yes man
good shout like that one
okay how did you get the nickname mamba
i was from harbour
i just
yeah i don't know who's set up by and i
just
was stuck with me and then everyone was
yeah just went to tajin and mumbo was
there right just yeah it was from a half
days bar and just stuck with me i
recognized once i shaved my head body
you know i was just like hey my boy
okay next one this one's from our
sponsor swish if you could get a video
shout out from any celebrity who would
it be and why
any celebrity um
i would probably go off
i like uh
kevin killing gatesboro he's a mean
celebrity um
and why because he like changed his life
around he was harder to like um once he
got famous
like started living like that party life
alcohol drugs all that stuff and changed
his left run and he's like a royal like
wise guy no
that or mike tyson my testimony
i just like guys that like change their
life around and just show like a better
way of living and yeah just have a
massive impact like what the what they
say and stuff like that so
yeah i'll be mike tyson will kill you
guys because yeah they changed their
life around crazy bro mate love that
might have to try and get them on the
podcast they sound like good yards
okay next one another celebrity do you
ever get mistaken for anderson silva
no
not that i don't know but is he the ufc
guy
yeah he must be um but he's the man if
i'm getting mistaken for him but that's
a compliment but
he's the man spider
man
if i'm getting mistaken for any of this
you but it's yo i'll take that as a
compliment
you'd be good
but if i'm getting compliments like that
right mostly from the spider he's a goat
boy he's the man
take that right because are your arms
longer than
they should be because you've got
massive reach
like you're fending stuff and you're
reaching um ufc i could imagine you're
having lethal reach in the cage i don't
know where i thought it was just normal
way to be honest
oh that goes on to the next one actually
uh tips for a killer fan
um massively long arms
um i can do a lot of bandwidth where um
grab a band check it on the pole and
just
get into like that routine of just
trying to fend and get some resistance
like sometimes you throw out a fin and
the guy running like trying to tackle
your
shoulders to get used to that bro so
um i'm like yeah get into that and just
practice my american you know just
practice
your skill shape or just when you're out
on the field or wherever and yeah just
throw it offended if you can right matt
you've put some deadly ones in the
season already yeah there'll be more
coming more coming
yes
okay next one best winger in new zealand
rugby
oh
i don't know it's hard to say bro
it's hard to say um
can't be yourself bro
name one better
it's
i'm more of a like i like
playing like a little bit so
when you find the best let me know
okay love it okay if you could play any
other professional sport what would it
be
um
everyone's been talking about league
hard out hey like there's been a lot of
chat
looking at the blues about league all
the boys league hits over there so
uh just i'm hearing a lot of chat like
charlie and all the boys are some of the
boys are keen to try is awesome you know
a lot of chat about that i've never
played league ever did you know the
rules and stuff so
another sport where i'll be
yeah league to be honest is that roger's
influence on the boys trying to
encourage him to have a crack
he's the plugin
he's the plug bro
how are you i think yeah roger have an
influence in there somewhere because i
see caleb clark came out saying it's
like a goal of his to play in the nrl
you'll be you'll be pushing him telling
him to get over there open up more space
in there all blacks
oh man i was
right if he wants to play league man go
for a man he's
he's talented by so given i'll give him
props on that man it'll be hard to stop
and leaks
what about basketball for you you're a
bit of a baller
i've i've only just played with like my
brothers and stuff like when we get time
and like my mates
apart from that nah just usually strip
over
there's a little bit like it's like
thousands stuff everywhere
you basically play rugby
okay last question uh best piece of
advice you have for a water lead
listener and there's been heaps of good
advice throughout this podcast already
so
um
i reckon the best advice i could give
anyone anyone listening to this
like i'll always say like chase like
your dreams and goals
and
don't limit yourself to like what people
say
then like if you're going to get advice
from people like get advice from like
your parents about love and stuff like
this but don't get advice about careers
and stuff from your parents like do you
wrong and
chase it and put like all your focus
into
like what you want to do with your life
on god you'll get like the benefits man
just chase what you want to believe in
your door
wow mate surprisingly powerful this
whole podcast like you're an
inspirational guy aren't you
ah no way man you're trying to do me bro
and you're doing it bloody well i really
appreciate you coming on the podcast
mate like i said at the start i think
you're one of the most underrated
players in the game love watching you
play love playing with you love coaching
you um you're one of the greats so um
it's been awesome having you on the
podcast and um hearing a little bit more
about your story
cheers man thank you so much for letting
me jump on this podcast finally bro and
we finally got it done so now cheers to
you bro matt you're a led
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you